I know that even in the United States
when you have someone like Donald Trump
I know that there is a lot of elitist
liberal reaction like here we see the
limit of democracy but in the wrong case
in the sense that you see stupid
ordinary people are seduced and so on
and so on well although norm Tomsky
doesn't like me very much I I admire him
sincerely and I must admit that I like
his term I think it's not just
journalistic term it's a concept which
he took over from American tradition
even mainstream right-wing liberal of
manufacturing concern you know democracy
is not only formal rules of elections
democracy is an entire thick network of
how political consensus is built a lot
of unwritten rules and now I think
United States are at a very important
moment at the moment when this machine -
- to build consensus it has broken down
now this moment which can be
catastrophic in such moments direct
fascism can take over but this can be
also moments when the left or whatever
would be the new left provides a new
answer so my first reaction to those
elitist liberals who claim you see the
stupid redneck white trash or whatever
are voting for Trump is yes but your
responsibility one moment of truth in
all those enraged people who vote for
Trump is that they nonetheless so
clearly that this traditional machine of
manufacturing consent no longer works
to put it in this slightly bombastic and
exaggerated Marxist terms the ruling
ideology uses mobilized a certain
machinery to keep people at track to
control the excesses and so on that
machinery no longer works and here I'm
not just the pessimist in contrast to
liberals for whom Trump is the ultimate
devil ooh it's a nightmare and so on I
claim no no it's much more complex of
course Trump is almost but not quite
proto-fascist phenomenon but it's
because they the liberal centrist
mainstream because they failed and
that's why not that I like in any way
Trump Trump is scum trash and so on but
my bad
is is this one first
Trump nonetheless if you are leftist you
should admire him sincerely he did
something wonderful he almost
single-handedly destroyed the Republican
Party that what I mean you have two main
vaguely orientations the Christian
fundamentalist in the party hardliners
in this Republican liberal enlighten big
business elite both of them are more or
less horrified of Trump and Trump is
vulgar but in his very vulgarity you can
see a common human business opportunism
now I will say something horrible but
for me people like Ted Cruz or you
remember eight years ago Rick Santorum
there something much worse Trump is a
dirty disgusting human being do you
really think that Rick hunter is a human
being I think there are aliens there is
something so monstrous about them so
that might from my second point is that
I never trusted this absolute obsession
with Trump oh now we should be all
together just to stop Trump for this
we sacrificed Bernie Sanders this is how
Hillary got us Hillary is not just LGBT
right it's a little bit more progressive
Hillary's today the vote of the
establishment even of the cult or
establishment free do you know that most
of the big names of of neocons from the
era of George Bush Paul Wolfowitz and so
on they moved to Hillary now Hillary is
not only the voice of the liberal
establishment
he's also the voice of let's call it
cold war establishment now in the last
days there are so propaganda against a
Trump saying oh but can we trust this
guy he will bring us into a new world
war know I'm much more afraid that
Hillary will do this so again in no way
I am for Trump he's he personifies what
I was talking about this disintegration
of public values of public learners this
obscene situation where you can talk
about whatever human again thinks which
years ago were unthinkable as part of a
public debate are now normalized open
racism and so on and here I think
political correctness doesn't work
because political correctness is a
desperate attempt when public mores all
these unwritten rules which tell you
what is this and what is not break down
political correctness tries directly to
legislate this expression is to be used
that expression is to be used and so on
and so on
what makes me afraid of this procedure
is the following do you remember how to
years ago or even three four sorry when
all this debate about torture begins
boarding waterboarding and so on
US Army did something very nice they no
longer talk about torture but about I
think the term was enhanced
interrogation technique and this is for
me
established
and version of political correctness you
know you put a nicer name like I can
well imagine the 10 years from now and
it's not a joke
I claim rape will be called well why not
enhanced seduction technique you know
like this basic politically correct idea
that you use words which will not hurt
the address she I totally subscribe to
this when we are dealing with all these
marginal sexual identities which can
traumatize you and so on but I
absolutely don't think that this is any
kind of universal right not to be called
in a way which hurt you let's take a big
criminal corporation boss who maybe also
wants to see him as a humanitarian no he
should be publicly called with words
which will hurt him and that's the whole
point that he should be hurt and so on
and so on so again I I don't like this
narcissistic idea of you know the
ultimate horizon is do you feel hurt are
you wounded or not and so on and so on I
mean this is a very ambiguous topic of
course you can in this way defend gay
rights the exclusion of LGBT people and
so on but then what would prevent what
would prevent white Aryans or whatever
white power people to say sorry guys but
we are hurt if you attack us like this
and so on
now in politics we have authentic
enemies everyone should not be respected
in politics and so on
politics is a real struggle of life and
death
[Music]